it seems today that all you see
are d-class and jumpsuits and contained
scps but where are those good
old-fashioned explanations on which we
used to rely
luckily there's scp explained luckily
there's a channel who positively can
talk all about those objects that make
us scream and cry
anyway
today we're going to be looking at what
freaking sweet scp lois
i mean
audience so put on your best pair of
green pants and a white button up and
watch out for any roaming giant chickens
because today we're going to be taking a
look at one of the strangest anomalies
in the foundation's history
scp-5981 otherwise known as nuke city
it's just another ordinary day in your
average suburban home where you live
with a bumbling idiot of a father a
caring though slightly aloof mother a
sister who seems to be blamed for
everything that goes wrong around here a
baby brother who you suspect is secretly
a highly intelligent evil genius bent on
world domination and your talking dog
whose sentience you have never once
questioned okay this might not resemble
your life exactly but it is definitely
just another average day in your life
you hear the front door ring and you
rush to answer it opening the door you
see that it's none other than matt your
friend who is absolutely obsessed with
family guy the animated adult sitcom
about the griffin family whose
combination of wacky antics pop culture
references and irreverent comedic
stylings is just about the funniest
thing in the world to matt who's
standing right there in a stewie griffin
t-shirt you're pretty sure matt's the
biggest family guy guy in the world and
while you think that the show is
slightly amusing you kind of admire his
unhinged fanaticism over it he's seen
every episode multiple times owns all of
the home media releases and even has a
multitude of family guy collector's
pieces and memorabilia including a
minton box action figure of peter
griffin signed by the show's creator
seth macfarlane if anyone's been keeping
family guy on the air for the past 15
years it's definitely matt and because
he's at your house right now that could
only mean one thing a new family guy
premiere that's right ever since matt
decided he loved family guy above all
else it would also meant he felt it was
necessary to make every single episode
airing as they first aired if matt was
standing outside your door it meant that
he wanted to watch a new episode of
family guy with you like you two usually
did together every week while a part of
you didn't understand matt's obsession
you still enjoyed the show and more
importantly spending quality time
together with your friend hey
he says in his best joe swanson
imitation you roll your eyes as he
waltzes into your house without any
further explanation matt excited as ever
walks into your living room and plops
himself down onto the couch as usual he
explains that a brand new episode of
family guy is about to air in an hour
and he was wondering if you wanted to
watch it with him well it's not like
he's ever given you a choice you think
you say the same thing you always do
sure matt you always know what my answer
to that question is as if matt expected
any other response from you he becomes
all giddy and excited oh man you strange
strange human being an hour later the
episode begins that broadway style intro
kicks in and you find yourself wanting
more and more to kick back and relax
with peter and the gang but something is
off it's not uncomfortable to watch or
anything but all the while you get the
feeling that this episode of family guy
is somehow different than all the others
you've seen the plot sounds like
something out of a dream even for a show
as strange as family guy in the episode
brian griffin the family's talking dog
begins dating a woman who he discovers
has fish-like gills on her body she
claims that she's a mutant and her body
has been altered as a result of exposure
to nuclear energy in her hometown a
place she calls nuke city in spite of
the woman's appearance brian continues
to see her over a series of dates peter
griffin however becomes obsessed with
the idea of nuke city having never heard
of it before and finding the concept of
a town in constant nuclear fallout
populated by mutated civilians to be
exceptionally exciting and he pushes
brian to stay with the girl over time
brian and the rest of the cast go to
visit his girlfriend and her family in
nuke city itself which is depicted as a
half-destroyed town full of strange
wacky mutants peter loves it so much
that in true family guy fashion he
decides to break out in song singing a
musical number about how much he loves
nuke city and how everyone should visit
the place and even offers detailed
directions on how to go there as the
plot progresses the griffins who are
eating dinner at the mutant woman's
house discover that their youngest son
the evil talking baby known as stewie
has disappeared unable to find him brian
begins to look a bit deeper into the
issue and discovers that his
girlfriend's father for unknown reasons
has kidnapped stewie and is currently
located at the town's nuclear power
plant brian's mind immediately jumps to
the worst case scenario which is that
stewie griffin was kidnapped in order to
be exploited for his high intelligence
and world-ending inventions ryan rushes
over to the power plant with the rest of
the family in tow wondering how and why
he would abandon his date in the middle
of their meal at the power plant brian
faces off against the kidnapper his
date's father after a lengthy
explanation of needing stewie to
manufacture a giant nuclear explosion
that would turn the entire world into
mutants a fight between brian and the
mutant breaks out thankfully the dog
wins and pushes his date's father to his
death as he falls into the nuclear
reactor this triggers a meltdown and a
consequential explosion which the
griffins narrowly managed to escape in
the episode's final scene brian is
thankful stewie is safe but laments the
loss of his girlfriend the ending joke
however is that the explosion caused the
residents of nuke city to mutate even
further with brian's girlfriend stepping
in front of the camera slightly out of
view as a gigantic sludge monster who
asked the dog for a goodbye kiss when
the episode finishes you're generally
surprised what a strange great piece of
entertainment matt absolutely loved it
and leaps from the couch over to your
desktop computer and immediately start
searching for guided tours of nuke city
but for some reason this doesn't strike
you as odd of course matt wants to visit
nuke city you do too the episode was
practically a glorified advertisement
for how cool the place is with all of
those mutants walking around and the
sweet feeling of nuclear radiation
permeating the air and getting into your
pores you wouldn't want to visit
anywhere else over the summer so you sit
down to start looking as well there's
not much you can find on the internet
about the place but there is a link that
seems to be the hub for all things nuke
city a website titled well visit
nukecity.com the page looks incredibly
high effort with all sorts of quality
photos of nuke city and its freakish
residents it even offered guided tours
and a shop with tons of nuke city merch
for you to purchase but most importantly
it has directions on how to reach nuke
city and they just happened to line up
with the directions that peter griffin
himself had given in the show as it
turned out nuke city was strangely close
to where you and matt lived in fact it
was located just off the interstate you
could go visit any time you wanted and
that's exactly what you were going to do
a few days later you packed your bags
for an extended stay and hit the road
following the directions to a tee though
unsure why a part of you felt like it
was all a dream
that you weren't actually going to find
nuke city but that couldn't be it had to
be real there was a family guy episode
about it and that website and more
importantly you and matt both knew that
it was real fortunately those fears were
quelled as soon as you entered the city
limits and gazed upon the town's
greatness for yourself there it was
nuke city looking just as dilapidated
and grimy as it did in the episode with
its red smog filled sky and its broken
down buildings that were all modified
into tacky tourist shops and attractions
it was
perfect and you couldn't be happier all
over the town were the mutated civilians
with their discolored skin and
cartoon-like features that made
radiation poisoning look like a fun
condition to have they seem to be
enjoying themselves even guiding tours
operating shops generally having a great
time living in their slightly
post-apocalyptic society over the next
few days you and matt lived it up in
nuke city enjoying the strange food and
sightseeing the freaky landmarks such as
a giant tower of human skeletal remains
or the mutated consciousness blob that
lived in what used to be a public pool
you were even encouraged to feed the
thing and toss some graham crackers from
over the balcony overall you felt like
you had a great time in nuke city and
the episode itself couldn't even compare
to how fun the actual place was you
experienced things in those few days
you'd never experience elsewhere such as
the nuke slides water park or winning it
big in nuke city's many themed casinos
you even brought a few pieces of
irradiated rubble for your family to
enjoy as souvenirs it was an
unforgettable experience and you plan to
go back someday at least if you got out
of the situation you currently found
yourself in with your entire home being
ransacked by black suited agents and
armed guards that's right only a few
days after you had returned from nuke
city you woke up to the sound of banging
on your front door and before you knew
it your house was being raided by what
you assumed was the u.s government
though you weren't exactly sure why
after being transported to an unknown
location and sitting down in a strange
looking room the suited men started
asking you questions all of which
pertain to nuke city you explain the
entire story how you and matt went after
seeing the family guy episode and how
you didn't see why there was anything
strange about going to an ordinary
tourist destination like nuke city the
suited man slides you a digital tablet
showing you overhead security footage of
what appeared to be your car exiting the
interstate on the day you traveled to
nuke city instead of traveling down the
extensive exit your car trails off into
the woods disappearing four days later
it reappears in the exact same spot
driving back home as if nothing happened
you're shocked where was the road to
nuke city you knew you had gone there
heck you even added the merchandise to
prove it you glanced down at your nuke
slides waterpark t-shirt pointing it out
to the agent the man got up and left the
room and you could see him discussing
something with a lab coat wearing woman
outside of the room when they come back
in it's with a syringe filled with a
strange looking orange liquid the man
tells you there's no such place as nuke
city and you have no recollection of
going there for whatever reason his
suggestion seems strangely appealing the
way he keeps repeating those words keeps
you entranced when you least expect it
the woman inserts the syringe into your
back you fall over slamming your head
into the table when you wake up you have
no memory of anything that happened over
the past week you remember watching
family guy with matt though you can't
remember what the episode was about for
the life of you and you remember having
a completely ordinary almost boring week
after that you never think of nuke city
or that episode of family guy ever again
so
what happened here well you and just
about every other person in the country
who watched family guy that week were
subject to an anomaly the scp foundation
has designated as
scp-5981
scp-5981 is a curious case indeed as the
anomaly itself isn't the episode that
aired but the concept of nuke city a
fictional u.s city located at the
intersection of route 93 and 93
alternate the city's fictionalized
history claims that it was founded in
the early 1940s but was subject to a
nuclear strike in
1966. the attacking party varies between
accounts with some saying it was cuba or
the soviet union or even an accidental
nuclear detonation by u.s military
personnel a broken arrow a very small
percentage of accounts of
scp-5981 claimed that it was the davide
empire the ancient anomalous society
that had disappeared centuries ago who
had launched the strike whatever the
case the story goes that after the
fallout most of the city's inhabitants
not only survived the attack but became
mutated in ways inconsistent with the
reality of radiation poisoning sprouting
extra limbs organs gills in a beneficial
way instead of a lethal one now you
might be thinking that
scp-5981 is a mimetic agent and anyone
exposed to nuke city will believe that
it's a real place but that just isn't
the case most subjects exposed to
scp-5981 do not believe that nuke city
exists and no future consequences will
occur it just so happens that you and
your friend matt were particularly
unlucky and fell consequence to
scp-5981's poorly understood side effect
which causes those exposed to nuke city
to not question it and fully believe
that the city exists those who do so and
attempt to visit the city will disappear
from reality shortly after entering
scp-5981's city limits once they leave
they'll reappear in reality with fully
formed memories of visiting nuke city
and possibly even some paraphernalia
related to the city such as t-shirts
with the slogan i survived nuke city
vials of nuclear by-products photos and
postcards negotiable us currency won in
nuke city's casinos or personalized
rubble intended to function as a
souvenir of course those who return from
nuke city are entirely safe despite
supposedly having visited a place with
as high a nuclear radiation count as
scp-5981
those who visit the area the town is
supposedly located in who are unaware of
nuke city will instead find nothing but
an abandoned department of
transportation building leaving the
city's existence accessible only to
those who know of it and fully believe
in it the foundation first became aware
of
scp-5981 nuke city after the
aforementioned episode of family guy
aired on television labeled season 13
episode vii within a day the website
visitnukecity.com appeared and according
to foundation estimates over 200 000
civilians visited
scp-5981 before the foundation caught on
that this phenomenon was anomalous after
this containment procedures were
established with the road leading to the
city being closed off and a web crawler
being programmed to remove any mention
of nuke city from the internet anyone
the foundation could track down as
having visited nuke city like you and
matt were paid a visit by foundation
agents interrogated and anesthetized but
most importantly the foundation made
sure to see what was happening behind
the scenes at fox studios who produced
family guy at the time
seth macfarlane the executive producer
and creator of family guy was given a
stern talking to by foundation agents
but even then his interview offered very
little understanding of how
scp-5981 originated or why the episode
was even produced the foundation forced
him to produce a statement that said
that
scp-5981 was not real and was simply an
element of fiction that the writers had
made up for the show after this the
foundation removed the episode from
public distribution and after three
months way after the hype surrounding
nuke city had passed a complete and
total information blackout on the
episode was put into place essentially
wiping this episode of family guy from
the minds of the general public through
the use of mass amnestization tactics
unlike those with mcfarland interviews
with the cast and crew of family guy
revealed that they believed that
scp-5981 was entirely real and that the
episode would shine light on a
lesser-known tourist destination while
mcfarland claimed that he had just came
up with a concept for the show while
under hypnosis the man revealed that he
had been approached by an individual
wearing all black robes and a
cone-shaped hood prior to the episode's
conception this entity instructed
mcfarland to produce an episode
revolving around a nuclear town where in
its climax a resident would be murdered
by being pushed into a nuclear reactor
mcfarland could not recall anything else
about this memory when brought back from
hypnosis still the foundation continued
to monitor for incidents revolving
around
scp-5981 while still some tried to visit
the city these events were far and few
between a few notable events include a
civilian who did not return from
scp-5981
but whose family was sent a letter from
nuke city hospital explaining that they
had been killed in a motorcycle accident
while touring the city another involved
a heavily injured civilian returning
from scp-5981
after an altercation with a street gang
their blood revealed traces of
irradiated nuclear radiation yet no ill
effects aside from those received in the
street gang beatdown were noted another
incident involved the television channel
cartoon network receiving a tape
containing an entire season of a cartoon
revolving around three mutated dogs in
their lives which was being pitched by
radioactive studios a company supposedly
located inside
scp-5981 the final incident involved
several u.s politicians visiting
scp-5981
and accidentally being caught in an
explosion that occurred as a result of a
janitor pushing a plant worker inside a
nuclear reactor in the city's main power
plant much like what occurred in the
episode this resulted in an explosion
that destroyed a massive portion of
scp-5981
the foundation could do nothing but
cover up the politicians deaths and
increase security outside of scp-5981's
entrance the case of scp-5981
is certainly mysterious and gives very
little answers but it's definitely one
of the most unique anomalies that the
foundation has had to deal with keeping
true to the spirit of family guy let's
end with a cutaway gag holy crap viewer
this is just like the time dr bright
visited nuke city now go check out
scp-2316 the bodies in the water and
scp-1472 multiverse strip club for more
anomalous locations that are
brain-breakingly strange